They say the book of Revelation is a
mystery, sealed and impossible to
understand. For some, it's terrifying.
But think about it. We watch apocalyptic
scenes in movies all the time. We hear
songs about the end of the world. If
we're not afraid of fictional doomsday
stories, then why would we fear a
prophecy that's true? Revelation isn't
about fear. It's about the revelation of
Jesus Christ. What if we could see the
visions exactly as they were given and
watched the prophecy unfold before our
eyes? Servio took on a challenge most
people wouldn't even attempt, capturing
every single verse of Revelation with a
powerful illustration in his book. In
this episode, we will expose endtime
movie propaganda through the lens of
prophecy and show how unlocking
Revelation for yourself will lead you
into a deeper relationship with Jesus.
Hey everybody, welcome to LED live.
Today we have a special guest. Servio
has created a beautiful book of awesome
artistic
expression but also like very thoughtful
for the book of Revelation. Welcome to
the show, Servio.
>> Thank you very much, Scotty.
>> But I want to say what's really neat as
we were kind of discussing this um each
one of these images is so thoughtfully
detailed out. I mean, can I just show
your Bible here for a second? This this
is not a uh this is not a piece of
artwork right here. Actually, it is a
piece of artwork. Um, but how many times
have you gone over these verses? This is
amazing.
>> So, here. So, this is the book of
Revelation. So, it it's interesting
because the book of Revelation is the
book that has more cross references,
>> okay,
>> than any book in the Bible. If you go
over all the rest of the books, um the
the one that has the most cross
reference is the book of Revelation.
>> About twothirds of it comes from the Old
Testament.
>> So other places in the Bible.
>> Yes. So if you're trying to understand
just this book, it would be very
difficult if you did not understand or
reference that.
>> Absolutely. You need the Old Testament.
It is impossible. Yes.
>> To understand the book of Revelation
without a clear understanding of the Old
Testament.
>> Yeah. builds on all of those things and
to have the um the imagery of the it's
it's like the final culmination of the
story.
>> So it's kind of God is saying I'm going
to tell you what the future's going to
be by the stories that had already
happened. That is what God is saying.
>> So but some people say one revelation is
a locked closed up book right like it
can't be understood and etc. And then
the Old Testament, well, we are New
Testament Christians, so we don't need
that anymore.
>> Yes.
>> But you clearly have made the
connections like what would you say to
people who might have that
interpretation
>> that they will find great messages
containing the Old Testament and the the
foundation of the New Testament is the
Old Testament,
>> right? and and the book of revelation
God left it so that we were able to
understand events in the future and in
order but we will need the the old
testament we will need the past to
understand
>> when revelation opens verse three says
blessed is he who reads yes
>> and those who hear the words of this
prophecy and keep those things which are
written in it for the time is near
>> so if it's a closed book
>> this is the testimony of Jesus it's not
the testimony of John it's the testimony
of Jesus this is Jesus saying, "You're
blessed if you read it. You're blessed
if you hear it. And you're blessed if
you keep the things that are written in
it." Well, you can't keep the things
written in it if you don't know what's
in it.
>> Yeah. If you apply it, you need to you
need to know how to
>> know what's in it to understand it first
and then you're going to keep it. Which
is very interesting. Is it is the only
book in the Bible that God promises a
blessing
>> and it contradicts the very the very
fact that is the least studied.
>> Yeah.
>> Book in the Bible. Now, I I'm thinking
when I was studying Yes. Um I was
thinking wait a minute God says there's
a blessing and it's not being studied
who's behind that right so who doesn't
want us to understand this and many
reasons are used for that they say it's
not important
>> uh the gospel is not there which is not
true it's in revelation 14 it's the
largest description of the gospel
>> um and um it's uh it scares it scares
people so it shouldn't scare people uh
many reasons in order for the people not
to understand or it's too difficult
That's the one of the most powerful one.
You're um you need a certain level of
understanding that is very high. You
cannot reach there. Therefore, it's not
for you. So, so those four are the
strongest reasons and then for people
not to understand.
>> What I think is really funny is like
people that say, you know, like, oh,
this is a scary book and we should never
talk about it. They don't even
understand that there's many things in
our world today. Take foran example
Nintendo. I mean, when somebody showed
me that there was like the stories of
revelation in Nintendo, I was like,
"What?" Like, you're telling me there's
like a a princess that's that's going to
be rescued by the prince, but then
there's this like, you know, dragon
character that's that's there to steal
him. And I mean, it's just like it's it
it was like people are already exposed
to these ideas and they don't even know
it.
>> And true. And if you would understand
that that Revelation is not a scary book
meant to scare you. It's a love story.
>> Yes.
>> It's a love story of how God is going to
remedy this whole thing. How it comes
together in the end and how he wins his
bride back from the dragon. I mean, I
think it's a beautiful thing.
>> Now, before you move on, um
>> I want to ask a question and I want to
pose this to everybody here.
>> Why is Revelation written in symbols?
It's why is it like a puzzle? That's
that's a phenomenal questions. Yes. So
so one of one of the answers for that
question is um the disciples asked Jesus
why do you speak in parables?
>> Mhm.
>> And then he says it was given to you to
understand the the mysteries of the
kingdom of God but is not given to them.
>> And then he quotes Isaiah.
>> He says for they they hear and they
don't understand. Mhm.
>> And they see, but they can like they
cannot see and they're not healed
because they don't want to be healed.
>> So then I was like, why would God not
want us to be healed? So the answer is
in Isaiah is that they don't want to be
healed, but God still have still have to
show them the gospel, but you have to f
He has to put a little barrier and those
that are interested will be able to dig
more and understand more and then that
will be they will be able to get to know
the truth. That's a test. that
>> that's a test. That's what it is.
>> That's kind of a really interesting
concept because it's like Satan is a
Bible student.
>> He can read this stuff,
>> but really the spiritual things are
spiritually discerned. So I I think that
the Holy Spirit is piecing this imagery
together and making sense of it. He's no
doubt reading it and trying to
understand it as well.
>> And even in Revelation 12, it says that
the dragon knows that he has but a short
time. Yes.
>> Where did he get that information?
there's nothing that he may information
that he may have access to that we may
not have access to. So he knows the the
closeness of times because he's reading
the book.
>> Interesting.
>> There's other practical reasons too. Um
it was written by John who was used to
writing in symbolic language. So if you
look at the book of John who's the
author of Revelation, he'll use things
like light and darkness to mean other
things. So even in his other writings,
he's writing with symbolic language.
It's not maybe as overt, but in um like
second John, it opens with the elder to
the elect lady. Who is that? Is he
writing to some lady? No, he's writing
to the church.
>> And another practical reason is here he
is exiled by the Romans, the very
kingdom, one of the kingdoms that's
revealed to be part of the problem
against God's people. So if he's just
flat out writing, "Hey everybody, uh
Rome is a big problem." How is that
letter going to make it off Patmos?
Right?
>> It's not right. And so God in his wisdom
has John Wright and symbols and and
since God's people
>> are are endowed with the spirit of
prophecy, prophecy isn't just about
prophesying. It's also about
interpreting prophecy.
>> Yes.
>> So he gives that gift to the church and
then by the Holy Spirit, they're able to
interpret the keys because they're in
the rest of the Bible.
>> That's awesome.
>> I want to take some steps back to answer
the question that you said about fear.
uh
>> that you see because uh it says oh it
causes fear. I want to read this. So
it's in Matthew Acts 22 uh 24:22
Paul encounters Felix. You know the
story. I'm going to read it. It's not
going to be too long. So it says and
when Felix heard these things having
more perfect knowledge of that way he
deferred them and said when Lisa the
chief captain shall come down I will
know the uttermost of your matter. And
he commanded the com the commandment the
centurion to keep Paul to let him have
liberty. 24 says after certain days he
when Felix came with his wife Drusilla
which was Jewish she he sent Paul and
heard him concerning the faith in
Christ. So obviously she told him hey
you got to listen about Christ and he
was interested in knowing about Christ.
And then it says here and heard him
concerning the faith in Christ. So he
was he was he was interested in knowing
about Christ what he did for us. But
look what happened after that. Verse 25
he says and as he reason of
righteousness
>> temperance and judgment to come. Felix
trembled
>> and answered go thy way for this time.
When I have a convenient season I will
call for thee. So this man had the
messenger of God right in front of him
and God wanted to warn him about what
was coming. When it says here the
judgment to come, obviously he told him
about prophecy
>> and he he was he was scared.
>> Mhm.
>> But God wanted him to wake up from the
circumstances he was living in.
>> And then he never heard about him. So
not all the time that someone feels
uncomfortable about a message, it's
wrong. Sometimes God wants you to awake
wants to awake you from your position or
your circumstances. Mhm.
>> So, yeah, it's not it's not always it's
not always wrong. And the Bible say it's
possible.
>> Excellent point.
>> I'm currently going through uh well, I I
just finished going through Daniel verse
by verse and then going through
Revelation now verse by verse and I just
finished uh Revelation 3. And the reason
why I did that is because I thought
surely if all these other pastors can
figure out these prophecies with the
same God that I serve, I should be able
to do the same. Asking the Lord for
help, asking the Holy Spirit. And so I'm
doing that now. And
um you know it's it's really powerful
when you read like Revelation two uh two
and three for example about the seven
churches like you said it it really
convicts you and especially when you
don't just read it but you figure out
the symbolism.
>> Yes.
>> And and maybe this is something else we
can throw out the table for people to
kind of pitch in. But you know how do
you how can you study Revelation? My
personally what I found is really
helpful and I'm sure everybody does it
differently is you know the Bible
explains itself. So I ask myself
questions. I stop. I don't read over it.
I say well why does it say here that
Jesus is uh you know dressed in this
clothing or his hair is this color or
there's this gold involved and he's
saying like buy of me gold or um you
know um I'll give you garments. What
does that mean? What does gold mean? And
then I just look up all of the verses
that have references to gold and see
does it fit in the context. Or I go to
the Strongs concordance. Strongs
concordance shows you how it was
originally written in Greek and and and
um and um Hebrew and it tells you the
original meaning of the word that has
been lost on us in today's English or
any other language or maybe even current
day Hebrew. That to me has been really
helpful. But I want to throw it out
there. Yes. How does everybody else kind
of see this?
>> I think it's kind of a bit like
planting. I imagine, right? When you're
planting something, the more that you
understand about the soil, the more that
you dig, the more that you know, okay,
for this plant to grow, it needs these
kind of things. When you know those
those elements together, it just like
enriches that understanding. And when
you're seeing that golden link through
the whole Bible and you're seeing like,
oh wow, this piece is connected to this
piece and this piece is connected to
this piece. I think it gives you an
appreciation for 2,000 years written
worth of material that it's like there's
no way this stuff can connect like that
unless there is an author that is not
us.
>> So the tricky part is, you know, there
there are things in the Bible that can
be taken into symbols because they're
real everyday objects that we
understand. Um, and there are things in
the Bible that are like obviously
symbols and and you have to discern when
those times are. I mean, the ones that
are obvious are obvious, right? But when
they're not obvious, then you have to
discern, well, is it is this meant to be
taken literally or is it meant to be
taken as a symbol?
>> And the rule of thumb is, you know,
generally it's generally perceive it to
be literal unless there's a reason why
you would perceive that it's needs to be
symbolic. And this kind of idea though
is is what the Protestant Reformation
was fought over. So you can easily
overspiritualize stories even the
stories of Jesus. You take for example
the the story of the good Samaritan.
Well some of the early church fathers
wanted to spiritualize that and and
assign symbols to all the different
things. Well,
who has the right to do that?
And it was the church of Rome that
decided we have the right to interpret
things how how we see it and outside of
the Bible instead let the Bible
interpret itself.
>> And so that's that's one area you have
to be you careful with. You can't just
say it means whatever I think it means.
>> That'll get you in trouble.
>> Well, in in how I have what I have
learned from obviously doing this and
studying, I think we have to go to
square one. Mhm.
>> And in the book of Revelation, the
square one is what is John seeing?
>> Mhm.
>> So once that's the number one, the the
the the baseline. Uh what is he seeing?
And then I I believe that once we know
what he's seeing, then we move to the
interpretation level, but we it's just
like a building a house. First we need
to know what he saw
>> and then we go to interpretation. So
that's exactly why we wanted to create
this tool which is it's it's just
showing what John saw an attempt to to
show what John saw and he said no it's
not possible no it is possible if you
read carefully uh you can do it and u
once you have that you can move to the
next level and that's why this book is
made for any Christian believer even if
you're not a believer just to go into
what it's saying and and then you can go
to the next level
>> I saw a page in here which had some
Greek written on a forehead.
>> That's correct. Yeah.
>> How did you determine which Greek word
would be written on the forehead?
>> Well, that one was um I'm curious.
>> Yes. Here. So, this one. So, the
>> there was another one. It was I thought
it was in Revelation 13.
>> Oh, yes. Yeah, that's true. So,
Revelation 13. So, let's go with this
one. So, the woman, right? So, uh that's
what the Bible says, but in the Greek.
That one's easier. That one's easier.
the one in Revelation 13. Everyone is
talking about Revelation uh 13:16, which
is the mark of the beast. But we need to
know this one.
>> Do we need to know the context? But um
anyways, so the question that you had
about this is the word mark in the Greek
language. I wasn't Yeah, just mark Mark
>> in the Greek language.
>> Yeah.
>> All right, I can do this.
[Music]
There are conventional ways of sharing
the gospel, but some may need a
different way of doing things.
>> Um, never mind. A way that gets the
message out with confidence.
>> Wow, cool shirt. What's it mean?
>> Oh, thank you. You know, we're all made
with a unique fingerprint, but we're all
God's artwork.
>> Wow. Where'd you get it?
Lightwear, wear your witness.
Um, here have we have the um what the
Bible is saying of what's going to
happen before the mark of the beast.
>> Have you seen how many podcasts have
people made about the mark of the beast?
>> Oh, I mean this
>> we've gotten
>> everyone's talking about it. All right.
So, what happened is that everyone jumps
and lands into Revelation 13:16, but the
context is this one. It's very simple
which is the first beast. The second
beast arrives and there's people in the
earth.
>> Then he makes worship
makes the people of the earth to worship
the first beast.
>> Yes.
>> Then this same power is a civil power
brings fire from heaven.
>> Uhhuh.
>> In front of the first beast. You see
everything happens with this first
beast. Now we have to identify this
beast. Now he deceives the people. If
you want to understand, anyone wants to
understand what is the number one
feature of the end time is deception.
>> Yes.
>> And it's so subtle
>> that if we don't have one, it is
written, we will be deceived. Yep.
>> Because it's the end times. That's
right.
>> And then we have here the scene of the
this beast, the be the people of the
earth. This is the United States. I'm
just going to drop that. Will make an
image to this beast right here. It's a
statue, but it doesn't have power. Who
gives power unto the image of the beast
is the civil power.
>> The civil power give um give power to
the image of the beast and then the u
the mark of the beast is enforced. So
very important to have the references.
>> Now what's really cool um explain to us
um why you have this leopard-like beast
and then
>> why did you choose a bison
>> because it says horns of a lamb.
>> Okay. So, so in the elements of this of
this um verse, we have the first beast,
we have the people of the earth, we have
the earth, and we have the beast. And
the Bible says lamblike beast. So, the
only element that is described is the
horns. Uh the horns is like a lamp.
>> Yeah.
>> But the beast is not described. So, I
chose this beast um because it will be
it will not fight with the word. So if I
were to put an elephant, that wouldn't
make sense because John would recognize
the elephant. They they've seen they
have seen elephants in the Middle East.
They know tigers. They know that's why
he didn't say it. But he didn't say I
just saw a beast. So I put a buffalo
because that that is not a beast that is
common in the Middle East.
>> Is this a buffalo or is it a bison?
>> Yeah. Yes. Bison. And then the reason is
that you know according to our
interpretation uh the this this beast is
the United States.
>> You know that's interesting because I'm
gonna tell you why. I'm gonna tell you.
So you see this earth,
>> the word earth in the Greek language is
the same word earth used in revelation
12. Revelation 12:16 says, "And the
earth helped the woman, and the earth
opened her mouth and swallowed up the
flood which the dragon has cast out of
his mouth." So this woman is the the
movement that started in Europe,
Protestant Reformation. It was bringing
back the Bible.
>> Mhm. And then there was persecution and
many moved to the United States. This
earth here that protected the woman is
the United States. Therefore, when you
see this
>> is the same earth, the same word. And
from that from that land will arise an
empire. So very important. It's not just
the government. There's been a
government in the US since
>> 200 years ago, but it's not talking
about a government. It's talking about
an empire. uh Daniel's chapter 7
explains that u u the beast represents
an empire. Yeah.
>> So when we want to if we want to
understand this and very important is to
that this applies the timeline applies
when the USA became an empire
>> and then that's when it starts.
>> And we see that the other beasts um also
had crowns on them. For example, this
was the beast that didn't have a crown.
So meaning it wasn't a monarchy. It was
a republic. But um we we have a whole
video on our channel as well. We can put
the link in the description where we
kind of go into that. Uh because some
people say, "Well, United States is not
mentioned in Revelation." Well, it's
symbolic, you know, you have to decode
it. You have to understand the symbol
symbology of Revelation
>> and Daniel because Revelation goes hand
in hand with Daniel to understand why
we're saying this.
>> And and it's very clear that the United
States is for good or for bad at the
beginning was more for good. Yeah.
>> And they more is more there's more uh
difficulties, but it is the center of
the modern world.
>> Yeah.
>> Because of their its influence. I like
how you matched the landscape as well.
Um, I know that was very intentional and
purposeful. Um, so that when you see
those two things together, you know that
that's really speaking about the same
imagery.
>> And also the beast, you see this beast,
the first beast,
>> it's in the wilderness right here.
>> Yes. Yeah.
>> And that wilderness is also mentioned in
Revelation,
>> Revelation 12 when it's talking about
the woman that flies into the
wilderness. So there the Bible is
actually speaking about physical places
>> and the landscape looks the same so that
you're linking to visually those similar
things that it's talking about. That's
really I like that.
>> Can you show us the pages of the woman
that has the the jewelry and the the
purple and the scarlet, but you added
white? you you explained all of this
before we start recording and I'd love
for you to explain it again on camera.
>> Uh so this is the famous harlot, the
great harlot. It's called the great
harlot.
>> So who does the harlots revelation 17
and it's saying here
>> that um it says here I'm just going to
read it because it's important. It says
and he carried me away in the spirit
into the wilderness and I saw a woman
sit upon a scarlet color beast. So the
beast is red. Yep. Right. And it says
full of names of of blasphemy. the the
name this is the word blasphemy that's
in the Greek and it says here
>> having seven heads and 10 horns and the
woman was arrayed in purple so purple is
there
>> and scarlet that's red
and deck with gold and precious stones
you see precious stones too having a
golden cup in her hand full of
abominations and upon her head a name
was written mystery Babylon the great
the mother of harlots and abominations
of the earth so when I illustrated this
one when I was I I was reading the text.
Um I was going to include only the
elements that are here, but I decided to
include white because in Revelation
18:16
says that this woman has white linen
here. says, "And the merchants of these
things
which were made rich by her shall stand
aar off for the fear of her torment,
weeping and wailing and saying, Alas,
alas, that great city that was clothed
with precious," and it says here, "That
was clothed in fine linen, purple,
scarlet, deck with golds and precious
stones and pearls." So he mentions the
the other elements, but the new element
is white, and he's talking about the
same one. It's the city is the great
harlot. So I brought white. Now why is
this important? The element of um red,
purple, white linen, gold, precious
stones and as a message in their
foreheads
>> that is all described in Exodus 28 to
talk about the dressing of the high
priest
>> which the high priest was and is still a
symbol both in old New Testament of
Jesus.
>> Yes. And is mentioned in uh Hebrews 4:14
that Christ is the high priest. Now when
once we identify Christ then we know
that Matthew 27 Christ offers a cup his
his blood his word
>> and then Christ uh is the high priest.
>> Hebrews is all about that. That's what
Paul wanted to help uh his people
understand that Christ is the high
priest. Now so if the high priest is
Christ and is having all the
characteristics of of of Christ of the
of the high priest
>> so this woman is replacing Christ.
>> Yes. Now an ele an important element
also is that in Exodus 28 it has the
high priest had the blue color. The blue
color but this one doesn't have the blue
color.
>> Yeah.
>> And in numbers 14 uh the Bible says that
no the the color blue God said
>> I'm going to put it in blue so that you
>> yes
>> don't follow after your desires. That's
what it's saying. And go after harlotry
and you obey the commandments of God. So
blue represents the commandments of God.
This is really interesting because um
you know this woman of revelation is is
also um you know the same as the symbol
of Babylon in Revelation, the fallen
city. It's also the symbol of the
antichrist.
>> And I was we have a guest that has been
on the show many times, James Bowen. And
he explained this once. I thought it was
fascinating that
>> um you know anti actually that word is
found somewhere in Thessalonians. can't
remember the exact verse of it but um
where uh it talks about the the
antichrist and it actually means in
place of
>> in place of yes
>> so so you see again here yeah it's not
against it's in place of and we know
that you know we can put a link in the
description for our video that explains
verse by verse who the antichrist is but
that the antichrist himself
>> or the the not the person necessarily
but the institution you know the the
that that really represents the
antichrist
has written in books. Yes, I am the in
place of Christ on earth. I mean that's
fascinating and it's been written
thousands of years ago.
>> It's actually well it's in John. It's
only mentioned in in first John and the
second letter of John. The word
antichrist is is mentioned three times.
Mhm.
>> Uh but it gives us light to see that God
was warning that there will be it must
be a very very influential system
because it will reach out to all the
world and take the mind of all the world
from Christ
>> from seeking to him to to this system
>> and it's it's it's described also in the
book of
>> we actually use that today in a in a in
a different way but in in modern terms.
You you've probably heard of anti-hero,
right?
>> Yes.
>> A lot of anti-hero
>> in place of
>> Are they against the heroes?
>> Yeah.
>> Sometimes,
>> not always.
>> They're flipped. Sometimes
>> sometimes they're in place of the hero,
>> right?
>> So they have these like gray morally
gray elements where they're like they
seem to be good, they seem to be bad,
you can't quite tell.
>> Similar with this power, right? There's
a lot of appearance of good.
>> Does it look like the enemy? Not
necessarily. Not all the time. But then
there are times where you're like
questioning it like well are they are
they not right?
>> I want to mention because you brought
this up very fascinating. I kind of had
this thought run through my mind. Um we
watch scary movies all the time as a
society.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean
>> some of the number one most watched
movies in our society are literally
about scary
>> this type of the end of the world and
scary type of things like this. And it's
like nobody's going we shouldn't be
watching that. That's just
fear-mongering.
>> You know what's interesting now that you
mentioned this, you remember that the
Bible talks about in in um John, the
gospel of John
>> that some of his followers left him. Do
you remember that?
>> So before they left him,
>> Christ said, "I am the bread. Eat from
me."
>> And then they said this teaching is too
harsh.
>> He was saying we don't like that symbol.
>> What you're saying, we don't like that
symbol. So in the same way, you see, but
they didn't love Christ. Do you
understand?
>> In the same way, when when we read the
Bible and Jesus says,
>> "This is my testimony."
>> And he says, "I'm going to show you
events, many say and take a step back
and say, I don't like those symbols.
>> I don't like that." And they're they're
taking the same decision than those
disciples did. even if they stay in
church because you may stay in church
and say I believe God but God comes and
brings this message and I don't want
that message
>> is is the real reason because they they
thought that that was just too far to
think that that was actually the flesh
of Jesus and and the blood of Jesus
>> they they if we if we could put it in
today's terms they thought it was
politically incorrect to say that
>> you see there's many things that God
says and many decide um I think that
that's not a good message but It is not
on us to decide what message is good or
not. It's just to ask God, okay, this is
in in the Bible. I'm going to read it.
You said that this there's a blessing,
right? I'm going to bless whoever reach
it. I'm going to do it.
>> I just think it's really interesting
that there is a church that actually
teaches that this is actually the flesh
of Jesus and actually the blood of Jesus
that you are partaking in. And
>> but if you take what Jesus said and you
interpret it literally,
>> yes. which is another conclusion
>> which was the position of of the leaders
of at of at the time of Christ.
>> Um
>> wait there their position of the leaders
at the time of Christ was that it was
literal.
>> They didn't like it.
>> Oh they didn't like it because they
thought because maybe they were like if
it's literal they're like we don't want
that. And this is actually why a lot of
the early Christians got persecuted by
the Romans because they're like well
they're just a bunch of cannibalists.
>> Yes.
>> Which you know wasn't the case. But it's
interesting because the the ones that
went to um northern Italy, see the
albenses, they were all reading this
book
>> and they were all able to escape what
happened in Christendom.
>> That's right.
>> During the dark ages because they were
following this message,
>> they were ready.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. Well, I think that we are coming
into a time that we need to understand
this message
>> and for sure there is a a beautiful
thing for God's end time church to
understand here and I think it is
possible to understand it.
>> Yes, I think um what can I share this
with you? So you know that um you know
what a meme is right? Of course. So um I
think that the memes have power. Why do
they have power? Because in one
snapshot, one picture you grasp a whole
a lot of messages.
>> Yep.
>> And if we look today, everyone's meing
everyone. Even short videos, but just
short short messages that you can get
the whole message. That's why God
brought this
>> because he knew that at the end there
would be a visual aspect. It's true. So
during the dark ages there was uh there
was no literacy. So the Bible brought
literacy to the to the world. And um but
it was about reading reading large
portions and and for a long time people
were just reading long paragraphs and
that was what was considered to be wise.
But today you watch videos.
>> You watch images and quickly quickly you
don't have time to read a whole like
paragraphs. No, I'm I'm too busy. So but
when you so when you have an image
you're able to remember God's word.
>> And that's why we have to have a a way
to remember God's word. That's why he
gave him gave us the visions. I do
believe that
>> especially for our time.
>> I think that's a beautiful link to to
modern society right now.
>> I mean, we use emojis.
>> Yes, we use emojis. Yes. But but we
we're very visual and and a picture is
worth a thousand words. I mean, that is
why I I think it's beautiful that you
you took the time to do this. This was
not thrown together. I want to say um
time and time again, this is not AI.
>> It's not AI. And I made it at a time
when there was no AI here. This is very
thoughtful in the way that you put this
together and every single detail in this
book has been thought about extensively
and tied to a biblical truth. Um, Serio,
how did you even get into this work? And
are you an artist yourself or or
>> I am not an artist. So, actually I hired
seven illustrators. So, I'm the editor
of the book and um it came out of my
interest to make the material to give
people access to get to know more about
the book of Revelation. Why Revelation?
The Bible has so many books. Why
Revelation specifically?
>> Well, it seems well prophecy. I've been
very interested in prophecy and it seems
the book that's secret.
>> So, um in order to open the the the
secrecy of this book, the apparent
secrecy is not it's not real. Uh because
it's called revelation,
>> right? To reveal.
>> But um but yeah, to in order to make it
to break that secrecy, just um I created
the images. I think this is a very
helpful study tool uh for anybody that
wants to understand revelation whether
you're an avid student, you already have
studied this pretty in-depth and or you
know you're just starting out and and
you know I think us working in the
creative industry we're all visual
people. Um I think it's great to see and
and you show can you show one more
image? Can you show the one with like
the lions with the snake tails or
something like that? I was looking at
that like spewing fire. I was like,
"Wow." Like,
>> and you were surprised. I I show this.
Yes, I show this one because they said,
"What is in the Bible?" Yeah, that's
what it says. Revelation 9:17. And it
says, "And thus u I saw the horses in
the vision and them that sat on them
having breastplates of fire and of Jason
and of brimstone, and heads and the
heads of the horses were as the heads of
lions, and out of their mouths issued
fire and smoke and brimstone." Yeah.
>> Uh, do you want to know that? I mean,
it's in the Bible. Yeah.
>> I mean, that's pretty cool. If you like
movies today, come on. You can put that
aside and check this out because I think
this is much better.
>> But how can they get the book when they
want to order it? And also, can you tell
us about the giveaway? There's going to
be a giveaway in a link for that in the
description.
>> Sure. So, you can get it at our website.
It's goldenfet.com.
[Music]
>> And uh Yeah. So, if you want to maybe
participate in the draw, you can send us
an email,
>> contact us through the uh through our
website or um subscribe to our
newsletter
>> and um and then I'll I'll choose one of
you.
>> Yeah, cool.
>> Receive one free book.
>> So, we'll put a put a description in uh
or explanation in the description how to
enter the giveaway and then people can
uh uh get on to that and get a book and
then you'll ship it to them as I'll ship
to them. Awesome. And then uh and then
how much is the book if they want to buy
it?
>> It's 57 on your website only or Amazon
or
>> It's only on my website. Okay. Yes.
>> Well, I think that's worth the money
because you're not just investing in a
beautiful book. You're also investing in
studying God's word.
>> Yeah. And we're we're we're also working
on other books. We're working on the
book of Daniel. And Oh, cool. There's a
there's a bigger project to make the
Bible.
>> Now, I want to ask one more question.
This costs money. Yes, it is.
>> How can they support you?
>> Uh, we have a Well, you can reach out to
us, send us an email, or there's a
donate button in our in our website.
>> Okay, we'll put that in the description,
too.
>> I'm going to give you a million dollar
idea. You need to start a podcast.
>> You need to slowly go over. I mean, look
at this Bible. It's just so cool. Like,
you have completely poured over this
material, and God has really allowed you
to um to put something beautiful
together here. Now you need to go and
teach teach the people.
>> Amen. Amen. I Yes, I that's that's in
the pipeline.
>> Okay, it's in the pipeline. Awesome. Be
looking out for um the Golden Trumpet
>> podcast. I don't know if that's what you
call it, but uh
>> just threw out a name there.
>> We'll we'll put a we'll put a link in
the description of how they can get in
contact with you if you if they really
want to pick your brain about this, but
thank you for coming over and uh and
blessing us with this. Well, thank you
very much for the invite and yes, I
really want want to encourage everyone
to just read the read the last book of
the Bible and if you want to get some
some good material to help your study by
all means just reach out to us.
>> Yeah.
>> Awesome.
>> And read Daniel as well. Yes.
>> It's connected to Revelation.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> If you like this video, like, subscribe,
>> and hit the notification bell so you
know when we launch new videos
>> and drop a comments below and we'll try
to get back to you if we can.
What?
>> Say that again.
>> No.
>> No. I don't know what to say.
[Music]